[Music]
a story in five words
as usual we're short on time so here's a
story in five words
monkeys made us into drunks
cat it's true apparently chimpanzees
like fruit that become ripe enough for
sugar to be fermented into alcohol and
we've evolved from this so this is why
we drink a lot i'm not a scientist but
i'm not buying it why i don't think the
chimps are drunk because that's low
alcohol content and they're also eating
food like have you ever eaten a bunch of
hot dogs and try to get drunk off bud
light not gonna happen have you ever
eaten liquor
chocolates filled with liquor you can't
get drunk that way yeah well that's
liquor that's higher alcohol content yes
it's basically like white claw and a
bunch of food you're you're just gonna
get bloated and go to bed serious lines
here gut fell watch it with her right
now
devito uh this assumes evolution which
is a lot to assume
so yes it's a theory
um
it's just a theory like gravity yeah
who's going to prove that yeah um yeah
these monkeys i say let them get drunk
because they have to reproduce which in
their case involves having sex with a
monkey
you know i think you you want to knock
back that is true too do you think
that's that you know that could have
been the reason why they invented booze
is because the how could you have sex
with a monkey that's they run they run
up into it right now against it since
we're there
don't do not lay down with a monkey
that's in leviticus
i think
i know it's against it
leviticus says a lot of things yeah and
i don't think there's a lot of stuff
that the bible's for no but i think on
the ark it clearly said no diddling
amongst just everyone staying there
stall and behave they call this the
drunken monkey hypothesis does this make
sense to you no it's true monkeys do do
that but unlike us they
just eat enough to have a good time
because they're not stupid because if
you get too
trashed in the jungle some eats you yes
so it's also it's also good medicine and
stuff it kills bacteria and stuff so the
monkeys are smart
they go and they eat they eat the
fermented fruit because it protects them
from
other diseases and stuff so it's not
uncommon and they cultivate it and they
fight over it and it's like their tree
it's like their keg wow so yeah it's
very it's very deep you know what smart
you made me think that the whole reason
why we created tools was because we like
to drink
right so we get drunk and we go how do
we defend ourselves when we're wasted we
started making tools but chimps
chimps instead
they just
decided i'll just kick back i'll just
guard the trees they'll discard the tree
but then we were like hey wow
let's make a spear
we can drink more if we have a spear
alcoholism brought us to the 21st
century
molly does this happen a lot on special
report where you can actually see bret
bear have an epiphany
about monkey spears and drinking yeah
this definitely is something that
happens all the time i think it's an
excellent theory yes but i just want to
say um
that these monkeys are not to be trusted
and i think that we need to be much more
on guard occasionally you get stories
out of the world you see india and
there's like yeah there's some kind of
pan troglodyte consortium that is i
think plotting takeover and we just need
to be on guard don't be fooled by their
pretend they're pretending yes they're
waiting for they're waiting for the
right time exactly to just rise up i saw
the movie i saw the movie
remember
joe what happened in the movie yes um
you're referring to any which way but
loose yes
by the way
these are these are monkeys these are
not the kind of chimps who rip your face
off no these are just plain old monkeys
these spider monkeys don't have
opposable thumbs so let them drink
they're not going to be able to light a
bong they do and they don't rip your
face off they rip your junk off
yeah they're great pickpockets robbers
yeah
they're all their digits work yes they
give massages for money in the streets
of india sometimes yeah they're clever
who pays for that well i do and you know
what don't be so quick to judge yes
that was one of the best vacations i
ever had monkey island he's got an
instagram page where the monkey does
i had a drunk orange before i got on the
show today
don't go away we'll be right back hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else